so who's my guest this week dr ngozi
akonjo iwala
harvard mit
ex-finance minister so far so
predictable but this head of the world
trade organisation is also breaking down
barriers the general counsel agreed to
appoint dr ngozi konjo uela of nigeria
as the next director general of the wto
the first woman the first african and
wanting to inject morality in how we
trade she's fought corruption and put
her own safety at risk by doing so
she's been named one of the most
powerful women in the world four years
running
the world trade organization
it made china
china made themselves they did a good
job
but they ripped off our country for
years
but can she counter accusations that the
wto is in hock to china and embeds
global inequality
i've got a feeling you're going to like
this conversation here's a taste
the goal i have is to make everyone
understand including the members
themselves sometimes when they forget
that we're here for people and when you
say people don't understand the wto do
you think the wto has to take some of
the fault for that well you're right i
agree with that it is the fault that
people don't understand really what it
is and what it does has being a woman
helped or hindered in your political
life
i think it's helped in the sense that
i'm i'm happy to be a woman i'm proud of
being a woman i'm proud of being who i
am
dr ngozi thank you for joining me
you have just reached a year at the helm
of the wto
i believe you threatened to walk out
last september or you could do you
hadn't bought furniture in your place in
geneva yet what what changed
i think that there was too much made of
uh what i was saying i didn't threaten
to walk out i told members indeed i had
not bought furniture you know to spur
them on you know to try and
negotiate harder work harder for me this
is a job i'm really passionate about
so even when i make comments it's all
geared to
getting more of the work done getting
results uh
if you're passionate about something and
you feel that it's you're there to
deliver for people so i'm impatient
uh for action for results
uh that's what drives me yes i suppose
it was just if you felt that the the
whto had done a better job at getting
if you like more respected by those it
seems to have lost respect amongst not
least america
well i i don't agree with the way you
characterize it it's amazing that even
when you say the organization has lost
respect
or is not supported one way you can
gauge that is whether members pay their
dues
if you've lost respect for an
organization and you no longer want to
be part of it you wouldn't support it
would you but i'm very proud to say that
uh including the united states all our
members are paying up
their dues they are very supportive yes
we do have some issues
that some challenges joe biden has just
said the us continues to have systematic
concerns with the the wto and at the
heart of this for those who aren't that
familiar with it you know there's this
concern about the requirement for
american workers to compete against
chinese forced labor but not stopping
sometimes the the theft of american
intellectual property and products it's
it's about how you have
made the playing field unequal that's
one of the biggest criticisms that
actually trump obama and biden have
agreement on
i think there's a misnomer here the wto
does not make the playing field unequal
the role is to level the playing field
and to put rules in place that will
ensure fair uh trade for everybody now
have those rules been changed in the
past 25 years the answer is no so
obviously some of the agreements need to
be brought up to date some of the rules
have to be looked at and new rules have
to be put in place so that is what is
the the issue here but to say that the
wto doesn't serve i don't agree with
that because uh 75 percent of world
trade still takes place uh based on wto
rules and in spite of the hot rhetoric
you hear between countries let's say u.s
and china trade between the two
countries is still quite robust no but
it's i'm going off the the signs from
the leaders of those countries who
actually have very different political
views that they've all expressed
frustration and you yourself have just
said those rules need updating
so what's the wto been doing
what has the wto been doing the wto has
been maintaining that level playing
field for most of the trade in the world
as i said in spite of all the criticism
75 percent of world trade still takes
place on the basis of those rules and if
it didn't exist like i said when i was
competing for this job you'd have to
invent it so the key issue is
how do we make the reforms that i need
yes that's that is my question that
sorry that that is at the house no
absolutely to point out that their
challenges their reforms i myself said
that when i was competing for this job
so we we need to embark on those reforms
and indeed we are
beginning to do that part of the reform
is to complete a multilateral
negotiations which the organization has
not done in a long time and that's what
we've been pushing for we're nearer
closer than we've ever been to
completing the fisheries subsidies
negotiations
and i think had it not be the fact that
we postponed
our um
ministerial meeting
from last november due to omicron we
could have been there by now so we are
regaining momentum you know to to try to
complete that we are also working on the
response to the pandemic the wto is
being responsive to a globa issue of the
global commons that is facing us us now
we've been working very hard on several
facets of this we've been working on
supply chain issues
with vaccine manufacturers this is where
we have a monitoring and transparency
function
that can help producers look at what is
happening to the supply chains
so this is very important
you have huge uh you know history and
experience having been chair of gavi the
vaccine alliance for a major moment for
the wto to perhaps improve uh the view
of it in the eyes of its critics where
is the wto going to come down on the
side of patents with regards to vaccines
and intellectual property or lifting
them for what's described as vaccine
equity around the world because i'm
unclear having read into this well first
of all let me start by saying that
vaccine inequity is plain wrong
and we've been very clear on that as the
director general of the wto inequity and
access doesn't serve anybody
even those who have been vaccinated
because because it could lead
to more variance multiplying now at the
wto
as i came in i realized that several of
the functions here could really be
useful in helping the the world to get
to a more equitable situation with
respect to vaccines like i said people
take it for granted but the supply
chains of vaccines are very complicated
because they have so many components up
to 280 for some of the mnra vaccines
if you have an export restriction or
prohibition on one of those products it
means the vaccine cannot be produced so
simply getting our members to reduce the
number of export restrictions and
prohibitions which were 119 at the start
of the pandemic and we are now down to
35 has helped to boost production in the
world helping the producers monitor the
bottlenecks in their supply chain raw
materials and so on has helped them know
what to do with that so these kinds of
functions are very important trade
facilitation we have a trade
facilitation agreement designed to make
goods move faster and this has been very
helpful to the manufacturers we are
meeting with the ceos of the vaccine
manufacturers the 10 of them every few
weeks to go over the issue that's one
side that is often overlooked because
people focus on the ipm patterns but to
make vaccines you need a smooth supply
chain you need manufacturing capacity
which we've also been working with the
manufacturers on and then you need
technology transfer and ip on the ip
side there's been a
negotiations as you know at the wto
they were going on for almost a year
before i came on the scene and it's been
very difficult because of course there
are two polarized sites proponents more
than a hundred countries who want a
waiver of the vaccine seen it has been
of the ip intellectual property seen it
as material to manufacturing vaccines
and those who believe that this could be
a detriment to innovation and to
research and development the
non-proponents now what we've tried to
do is to bridge the gap between the two
we're still working on it we're not
there yet but we're inching forward
and you know we have a process going on
now how do you do that when you say it's
two polarized sides like that when you
talk about bridging the gap you're the
director general how do you go about
doing that and do you see an answer soon
well actually the way things work here
members are supposed to talk to each
other and try to bridge their gaps but
i've stepped into the process
to try to help that along and it's well
known so i can say it we've trying to
work with four countries at the moment
the us the eu india and and south africa
to see if we can come to a framework
which we can then share with the rest of
the membership fairly quickly
so we can get to agreement on a text
that everybody can support it will be a
compromise solution between the two
sides so by its nature a compromise will
not be satisfactory to all sides but it
is there's what we call a landing zone
uh it will be a workable
compromise and that's what we're aiming
for what could that look like
in the sense of will it be that certain
vaccines uh that the patent is waived
and others aren't no absolutely not and
i'm afraid emma that this is one of the
things i cannot do we are in the middle
of this negotiation so uh just talking
to you about it puts it in jeopardy so
we have to be very sensible um i cannot
go into the details of what it could
look like when the agreement is made we
can talk about it i've got to try and
get as much as i can though to to
understand i suppose from your
perspective
how important is this particular landing
zone to get right in terms of whether
the wto should exist at all because
there are some who really don't think it
is fit in its current state
well the wto i don't think we should mix
up all sorts of issues i've already made
it clear that the wto is playing a role
that people don't appreciate in the
world if it didn't exist there would
really be trouble in the multilateral
trading system that's not to say that
the wto does not have challenges
and has to be made fit for purpose
uh but this uh this issue of the ip
waiver
there is a suitable compromise that
would allow those who want access
to be able to
meet some of their needs whilst making
sure that we don't disincentivize
research and innovation which is what
the non-proponents want so that's the
kind of middle ground we're looking for
so nobody will have hundred percent of
what they want but there'll be a
workable solution that both sides can
live with and the workable solution so i
don't know a farmer in america who's
lost his job because of unfair
competition with china what's a workable
solution that the wto comes for him or
her if they're thinking well i'm not
sure america should pay their dues to an
organization that has still failed to
reform trading practices between two
giant members let me repeat one thing
wto is a member-driven organization so
the members need to talk to each other
negotiate it provides a negotiating
forum
you know so for them to approach each
other talk to each other to try and
resolve these issues that being said
there are certain agreements that have
been in place at the wto which if we
renew or revamp
could help with some of these issues but
first we have to get our facts right
because a farmer has or
somebody working in a coal mine has lost
their job we really need to look at the
factors behind that
you know it's sometimes lazy thinking to
just blame trade sometimes it's
technology that that is the cause of
that displacement and you need
governments to implement active labor
market policies to solve it sorry but if
i may you know political leaders and
i've named three american presidents who
are not aligned always it's fair to say
politically
have all said if i say the trump
administration accused the wta of being
completely inadequate and joe biden to
repeat says the u.s has systematic
concerns and we've also seen you talk
about paying your jews that's one
indicator if a country is happy but it's
now not going to
the biden administration is not going to
appoint new members to the panel who
look at trade disputes with the wto what
i'm trying to say is there is a
narrative here where in one hand you say
it's a member organization they've got
to talk to each other but you're
receiving millions and millions of
pounds and dollars to help
countries do what they can't do on their
own so you can't you can't say it's up
to countries and then still have this
arbitration role
no you i think people don't understand
the wto the wto is a member organization
that has a secretariat that supports
members to get these negotiations done
so there's no
kind of wto sitting out there it's the
members are the wto are you saying joe
biden doesn't understand the wto because
i'm taking my lead from the president of
america no i'm saying that the way
you're characterizing it
it's not the way it is let me tell you
what people are frustrated at if members
have not been able to talk to each other
with the support of the secretariat to
solve some of these problems of course
there's frustration and it is true that
the
u.s you know said they don't like what
goes on with the dispute settlement
system and that the way the the system
runs the appellate body has overreached
in terms of the way it makes judgments
that has been a complaint over many
administrations and what's the answer to
that the answer is that we should reform
it which is what we are presently
discussing one of the things we want to
make sure we table at our 12th minute
syria which is now going to be on june
13 is how do we indeed reform do the
fundamental reforms of the wto
um how do we rework the dispute
settlement mechanism
so that it can serve all the members the
way they want if i may there's presently
a dispute in the wto amongst the members
about how to handle disputes yes right
okay and when you say when you say that
is true when you say people don't
understand the wto do you think the wto
has to take some of the fault for that
but it's this organization that isn't
well understood around the world and
people don't think it provides value for
money sometimes well you're right i
agree with that
and that is i think it is the fault that
people don't understand really what it
is and what it does and it's
mischaracterized including the president
of america i'm not saying that i don't
want words put in my mouth i think the
president is not satisfied with the way
the organization is working because they
are not happy with the dispute
settlement mechanism and some of their
complaints are well-founded that's why
we need to reform the dispute settlement
system but to reform it is those same
members that have to sit around the
table there is no rescuer coming from
outside you've not got an easy job have
you you really don't the u.s and all the
others have to sit around the table and
agree on how they're going to make these
reforms bid dispute settlement be it the
monitoring function
now all i can tell you is that as the dg
we try to support them to do that and
now
we are looking at the reform of the wto
core functions as one of the big
subjects that we're going to look at at
the
12th ministerial so we will start the
discussion and the debate there and then
they will agree eventually on how they
want to move this forward what gets you
out of bed in the morning what motivates
you you could have been happy i think i
have one of the most interesting jobs in
the world that's why i applied for it
let me tell you something this wto
the purpose of this was inscribed in the
charter when it was created in 1994 in
the preamble to the marrakesh
agreement
and it says that the wto's purpose is to
enhance living standards to help create
employment and to support sustainable
development in other words it's all
about people and that's what drives me
and the goal i have is to make everyone
understand including the members
themselves sometimes when they forget
that we're here for people you're right
the ordinary person on the street in my
village in nigeria needs to know why the
w2 exists and what it exists for because
it's doing some very very important and
good things so that's what drives me i
get up in the morning ready raring to go
to work because i want us to deliver for
people the fisheries subsidies agreement
let me just take that they're 206
million people that depend on fisheries
in the world if we if we're able to
conclude that deal we will stop over
capacity and overfishing which is now
almost at 50
and that will secure the livelihoods of
so many people when we get to the
response to this pandemic and we have a
package agreed by all members we have
been contributing already very
materially to solving the issue of
vaccines production and access which i'm
very proud about uh and and that is
something that delivers for people so
that's what i want everyone to know the
wto is about people
you have been credited in your time in
politics in nigeria which you've just
mentioned uh with saving a lot of money
for the country you're in fact nicknamed
the nine billion dollar woman for for
making sure that you could try and face
down as much corruption as possible what
is it about you and your style do you
think that you hope helps people get to
a more agreement to a better place
well i think it's because i never i
never give up
i'm an optimist by nature
i i am very enthusia i never take on a
job unless i'm passionate about it so i
get up every morning wanting to go and i
think people see that they also see that
no matter how difficult the situation is
i will not give up i will work as hard
as possible to push for results i'm very
results-oriented
and that's what is attractive at the wto
we can achieve results that will benefit
people so people see that and i think
they can relate to the sincerity that i
have for the job has been a woman helped
or hindered in your political life
i think it's helped in the sense that
i'm i'm happy to be a woman i'm proud of
being a woman i'm proud of being who i
am from where i am so when you have that
self-confidence it helps you to lead
of course when you're a woman and i've
written a book about it with julia
gillard the former prime minister of the
of australia which is uh quite popular
now it's called women and leadership
real life's real lessons and we look at
eight women leaders and other selves you
will see that when you're a woman in
leadership there are a number of
challenges uh that that confront you
along the way from looking at how you
handle issues you cannot be too soft
because people will then criticize you
for being too soft but you can't be too
strident
because then they think you're overly
aggressive so women leaders we found
always watching their style to make sure
that they balance it out but at the end
of the day what most of the women in
leadership have found is that you just
have to be yourself you lead best
when you're yourself because you're
authentic and you don't have to try and
be anyone else so of course there's been
challenges along the way if you're a
woman of color there are even more
challenges
along the way you know when i walk into
a room people are surprised when they
see the way i'm dressed which is the way
i've always dressed and you can see
some assumptions on the faces of some of
the people uh you know because they look
at your parents and make some judgments
maybe this person cannot
handle the job or whatever but the
minute i open my mouth and talk about
the substance people forget that so i
don't spend time dwelling on whether i'm
a woman or a woman of color i dwell on
what do i bring to the job and what has
my knowledge
helping to change things in the place
and that's what excites me i think when
people see you have what it takes to run
they they relate to it i've been a
manager for instance for my a long
time in my career the world bank which
is a huge organization i've been
minister of finance with thousands of
people you know uh under my in my
ministry
so i i have experience so when i come to
a job at the wto i try to put that
experience to the benefit of the
organization and what i can say is um
[Music]
you know i'm i love the job i have to be
very honest but i also have to be honest
that i do get irritated when we don't
move quickly towards results
maybe that's what the only aspect so
but i use my experience to make try and
make things work have you bought any
furniture yet oh yeah it's too late now
dr ngozi thank you very much indeed for
your time and your experience thank you
emma thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again stay safe and
goodbye
[Music]
you